[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
hello everyone um
welcome to culture binge this is the
wisecrack podcast where we dive into
everything going on
in the current cultural zeitgeist i'm
michael and i'm here as always
with serbia how are you doing serbia hi
i'm well how are you
you know as good as anyone can be um and
then of course
wisecrack head honcho of sorts writer
extraordinaire the man with the plan
alec how you doing alec i'm great maybe
i think so yes
that's fantastic um as we sit here and
see
if i actually ruined the stream
and just destroyed the work that our
industrious producer has done
we're going to get into it we got a lot
to talk about today um we're going to
talk about and i know everyone was so
excited that we talked about sports last
time but i'm going to talk about that
again and update
everyone what's happening with all these
sports bubbles we are going to talk
about the
free brittany movement i'm very excited
to learn more about this
and then we're going to get into some
pandemic related content and talk about
some very good media companies and the
good
content that they're making but in the
meantime
you know we need to start slaps and
chaps this is where we talk about
something
that's that's great that we're loving
since we were last together and
something that chaps our ass so
sir let's start with you what is
slapping and chapping in your wonderful
life
so what slaps is um i have a lot of
friends who live in europe
and i'm seeing them travel they're
talking about where they want to go on
vacation
and i'm like ah this is so nice for you
um and so seeing pictures of like
beautiful landscapes in switzerland
and hiking in italy and
beaching and portugal it's very
depressing but also very exciting
for them um i'm also running out of
netflix
and other shows to watch so if anybody
has any recommendations please let me
know
what slaps i really love shit's creek
it's my favorite show
in addition to uh downton abbey and i
just learned that they were nominated
for
so many emmys and i'm super excited for
them um
and it's really been a lifeline for me
this whole year so i'm just really happy
and really excited for all the casting
crew
that's awesome that's fantastic such a
good show if you haven't watched it yet
everyone
watch it uh alec how about you what is
slapping and chatting in your life
uh i just really blew through the book
world war z
uh it's really really good i like it i
think uh
in the pandemic i'm into uh zombie
fiction or just
things like that it might be too close
to home for some people at this moment
in time
but it's really good in the movie it
just gave me extra
uh insight into why the movie is awful
um but as far as what chaps
uh this came out i think a week or two
ago dsw the shoe company put out
uh i think the dumbest ad of a very long
time
can we can we cue that up joy team
what's the fastest way to save date with
vip rewards guys give us your email and
address don't
use in-store what else roger it's your
birthday well it is not my birthday
five dollars you get a five-dollar
reward on your birthday everybody gets
five dollars on my birthday no but they
do get free shipping
[Music]
yeah uh for anyone listening to this and
not watching
they are a bunch of dsw employees are
talking with mask on as
the responsible things do except they're
pulling it down every single time they
talk
uh and it just makes me so because i
think
you know modeling good behavior not that
i
exactly expect [ __ ] dsw to do it but
i think a lot of people have this idea
that like
nobody can hear them on their cell phone
unless they pull their mask down or
uh brian from real engineering had a
tweet a while ago that the flight
attendant on his flight
kept pulling down the mask to talk to
him he's like you really don't need to
do that
um it just really chaps my ass
it should i was at a coffee place well
outside
a coffee place where you weighed six
feet apart in order behind a fiberglass
window
and there was a woman ahead of me who
like had her mask on and then got to the
front and immediately pulled it down to
interact with a human i was so
upset so people like that exist that's
horrible
make better commercials yeah um i'll be
quick
um slaps and chaps uh so i this is
gonna make me sound so lame everyone
else already knew the show was good
so many of you who watch and listen to
our content have told us how good it is
for various reasons i had to watch a few
episodes of the show dark recently
and it's so good and i'm kind of
obsessed with it now and have a bunch of
tabs open
on like god particles and like einstein
rose and bridges
and wormholes that maybe spoiled some
things my bad
but it's just so good if you're looking
if you haven't watched that and you're
looking for something to watch
it's good it's a little dark though um
that didn't mean that in a pun way
it's german shows and northern european
shows in general get a little grim with
the violence
um chaps oh this will be simple
um sleep has been chapping my ass i'm
bad at sleeping and recently i had a
stretch where i was really bad at
sleeping
and it sucked i eventually got control
of it but the thing i hate about when
you like do you guys know about sleep
debt
conception right oh i thought it was
okay this is something i've believed in
for a long time the concept of
someone sleeps in the comments okay yeah
correct us that this is wrong
but sleep debt is the concept that like
if you lose let's say two hours of sleep
at night for five nights in a row
then you have a 10 hour sleep debt you
have to make up for so i currently
feel like i'm going through a a sort of
debt consolidation period in regards to
sleep
but maybe i'm wrong and that's
non-scientific nonsense that alec could
debunk
so that's my slaps and chaps yeah but
let us know
if that's real yeah we'll i'll get back
to it though i'm just one of the people
who's bad at sleeping it's not a skill i
have i am too
yeah it sucks have you tried have you
looked into the comm
app they have these sleep stories that
are kind of cool
i have i haven't tried them but i will
i think i'm curious if you're in the
chat now let me know if anyone else does
this
i have the decade long habit now of
always listening to like podcast or
audiobooks when i go to bed
i think it helps me fall asleep my
partner thinks it's a horribly
destructive habit that i have that i
need to stop at all cost
so let me help you know if i should
yeah okay well if you're in the chat let
us know if you have any sleep habits
because i'm just curious maybe that's
too personal and i'm sorry if that's too
personal
um now we have a lot of great tahoe go
ahead alec oh i was going to say a few
comments
uh honey creep and says sleep debt isn't
real but i think health consequences of
sleep
deprivation can add up but also the dude
abides
wants to ask serbia if you've tried
shows from other countries
that's what dudabid's been doing oh
that's a great idea
i haven't done that um although i did
watch some show from norway a couple
months ago but i can't remember
um was it occupied no i can't remember
anything about it
this is a it's been a dark year for me
um but if you have
any great shows around the world please
let me know
that's a great recommendation not that
you divides is capable of a bad
recommendation
but that's a really good one um and yeah
there's some good services online to
watch european shows or just get a vpn
log into many european tv network
stations and let you watch stuff
for free um so before we get into the
topics i do
want to tell everyone you maybe already
know about this about wisecrack's
patreon page so if you go to
patreon.comwisecrack
we have a patreon page there's a bunch
of different levels and it's great for
many reasons one is
we always get comments on every video
that complain about ads and listen
it's it's a necessary evil it's the name
of the game we want to make videos you
want to see them
advertising helps us do that but if you
really hate it um we put ad-free
versions of all our videos up on the
patreon page
uh we also have a dedicated discord
server if you're a patreon you can jump
on there you can talk to alec you can
ask alec for recipes you can ask alec
for advice
in your personal life alec is there 24
7. he does not sleep he's in the discord
channel
um i promise to pop in okay you can ask
me where mike michael lives
yes we are doing a giveaway for my
address we are going to doxx me
as a fun bit uh so you can do that as
well um and we
started something new last week which is
doing patreon hangouts where
a few of us are going to jump on a live
stream kind of like this just for our
patreons and talk about
new videos we're working on talk about
uh things we haven't been able to work
on and why
and take questions from you all so if
that's something you're interested in if
you think it'd be fun to
chat with us more see videos without ads
be a part of some new exclusive content
we're trying out
and just supporting us in general as we
try to make the stuff that you hopefully
like because we love making it
check out patreon.comwisecrack and maybe
give it a go
right shouldn't that sounds great i want
to join and put you
on there well we'll get you on there you
don't even have to pay serbia that's
that's the bonus of being on culture
binge
oh but we know why i mean
they made me pay so i have no idea why
serbia gets in for free but such is life
okay so let's get into our topics i'll
be quick with this because we i talked
about it last time
and if anyone knows this you know we had
a big revolt because i talked about
sports got a lot of hate mail to various
addresses that people think are mine
but last time i talked about the nba
bubble in particular and this idea of
sports leagues trying to start up again
in america via
various mechanisms now the mba's plan
once they're going through with is they
got a big area of the disney
resort in orlando along with the disney
wide world of sports complex they took
everyone there they quarantined everyone
for ten seven to ten days
and then when they got there they
literally had people in a hotel room
couldn't go outside
got tested in front of their door got
their meals delivered all this sort of
stuff
and in game started last week the
official season starts uh this thursday
as of right now it's worked um they have
zero positive test results since july
20th
so since they've locked everyone in
including reporters they've had zero
test results and they've shown
wildly enough that quarantining wearing
mask when you're out in public
and regular testing really helps things
uh so
the mba situation has gone pretty good
uh one fun story though is a player
named lou williams from the los angeles
clippers
got an excuse to leave quarantine and it
was for like family reasons i guess
but then someone posted instagram photos
of him at a strip club in atlanta
and the nba said yeah and they were like
we didn't give you permission to go to a
strip club in atlanta
um so now he has to quarantine for 10
days oops of all the places to be during
a pandemic
like definitely not a strip club with
you know no offense to
the the wonderful workers there but just
don't just don't go to a strip club now
everyone
yeah and it was there was a rapper whose
uh name i forget
who posted the instagram photo of lou
williams on his story then deleted it
and then said was just thinking about my
buddy and posted this picture of a time
we hung out
months ago and then it was it was
quickly corroborated that he was there
but so the nba situation all things
considered is going good and people are
even talking about the nba bubble
as a microcosm of things we could do on
a larger scale
to curb and control the spread of covet
so that's good
bad news with sports would be mlb
major league baseball they just started
the season back up
and things are not going well
now baseball unlike professional
basketball
isn't doing a bubble teams are playing
games in their divisions
at their home stadiums they're traveling
by plane and bus to get there
there are no fans in the stadiums um
and they're they're doing semi-regular
testing but there's travel involved a
lot of people are on a bunch of other
people and in baseball players
more than nba players i don't know why
have been a little bit more uh mask
truther whereas most of the nba players
if you see pictures of them in their
facility and note they're already in a
bubble already getting tested
they're still wearing masks when they're
not doing games or doing media stuff
a lot of baseball players have like made
fun of it and are not wearing masks and
dugouts or
when they're traveling and stuff like
that which sounds like a recipe for
success
except for we just found out uh well we
just found out about more cases
the miami marlins baseball team
currently has
17 positive cases amongst its players
and coaches
they've now had to postpone their next
six games at least which is 10 percent
of the overall season
they exposed at least i think two other
teams one for sure to this when they had
active cases they've been quarantined in
a hotel in philadelphia
a story leaked that one of the players
from the team got
tested positive and everyone knew and on
a group
chat the team decided to play a game
anyways so they knew there was active
coveted cases on their team
and they went and played a game um in
philadelphia against the phillies
so now that that team's getting tested
that team went and traveled to play
someplace else so they're shutting a
bunch of games down
another thing that's happened with
baseball is there is a one canadian team
the toronto blue jays
and the canadian government was like
hell no we are not letting professional
sports happen
right now in a stadium in our country so
that team has had to figure out where to
play
had offers in both buffalo and
town in florida so the baseball thing
has gone very poorly
we are only a few games into the season
and already one team has almost
20 cases one of the issues of course is
if let's say three teams get 20 cases
and have to shut down how do they keep
playing games
um so baseball is not looking good last
thing i'll touch on
wait they're they're when they're
traveling they're they're on airplanes
with normal people
they are going to locate i think they're
chartering i think they're chartering
for most of the flights yeah but they
are they're flying charter
but they're staying in hotels and you
know you compare this to the nba
where they are staying in a quarantined
bubbled hotel with everyone getting
tested
um i don't think they have those same
safety measures for professional
baseball players
so are there any consequences for the
marlins considering that they've done
this
um as of now as of now there hasn't been
um the the peep the person who's in
charge of major league baseball
said like you know if they have to
change the season around because a team
can't play they'll kind of cross that
bridge when they'll get to it
i think the story just leaked within the
past 24 hours though that the players
were aware of this
and on a group chat decided to play um
so those are the consequences i'm aware
of right now and then shame is a
consequence i think right
i feel like they should not let them
play this season like you can get
you get what do you get like suspended
for multiple games if you get out of a
dugout during a fight and start playing
with people so
well here's the problem right so they're
playing within their divisions so if one
team leaves the division
then there's not enough games to be
played in that division to then
determine who who has the record that
gets them into the playoffs so
the league working is kind of dependent
since they're still in the regular
season
well they just started the regular
season everything's dependent on every
team
being able to play 60 games the same
amount of games amongst the same teams
in their division so it throws the math
off
so i don't know if the nba is like this
but
basically they've set up like a
quote-unquote safer environment
where literally if anything goes wrong
they cannot do anything about it
wait in baseball yeah like by design
like
let's just say a whole team was like
sick in the hospital
not that the whole team's gonna get
hospitalized but you know what i'm
saying like there's nothing
once they start it they can't stop the
machine is kind of what you're talking
about yes
yeah i think it's it's either the the
machine keeps running through problems
or it breaks down completely and i do
think
there are sports writers who are saying
at this point it really seems like this
might be a disaster and they might have
to stop
it anyways and like the nba which has
done a much better job
their commissioner adam silver has
acknowledged at various points like
it might not work and if it's not safe
we'll stop which i think has been good
at least from a pr perspective
for them but you know in the nba you're
locked down you're getting your kova
test
every day baseball not so much um last
sports thing
i'll touch on a little bit is uh the nfl
uh
a season sport league that was not
started when coveted broke out
go ahead they're doing a black mirror
with the fans in the audience
well yeah they're something like that
right um are they using wait do you know
about this are they is it screens
they're using
they're they're they're like digitally
inserting fans i saw an app
and it's literally 15 million merits
from black mirror
that's so weird who wants to watch that
but the nfl might not happen their
preseason has already been canceled
after the league and the players union
couldn't come to agreement on safety and
covet precaution
a lot of players have been publicly
anti-what's going on
but like baseball but in an extended
version they're just trying to have a
normal season where
all the teams are traveling around the
country playing games and of course
more so than any sport football is one
that's dependent on screaming breathing
touching being very close to one another
even if you have a helmet on
so not looking good there but more so
than any league as well the nfl seems
like they're going to push forward no
matter what because freedom is football
and football is freedom
last time i was [ __ ] really hard on
the nba and i just want to
retract those statements
[Laughter]
well no but i i think we could say that
like i don't think we should have sports
but i think within bracketing that the
nba is doing the most responsible job
yeah that could be done doing something
that maybe we shouldn't do
yeah i think like i was very skeptical
and i think i still am skeptical we
should keep being skeptical but
maybe good job nba so far
yeah good job so far um we'll see how it
goes
if i were a betting man and i'm not i
don't like gambling
i i don't think anyone should do it i i
would just bet that the
baseball season doesn't finish and maybe
even the football doesn't start
that would be my cynical bet there
um i have a question would either of
y'all just because maybe you're starved
for content
be curious to like watch some nba games
once the season starts for something to
do
like me either of you there's two of you
one of me okay just curious serbia any
chance you tune in and watch some nba
basketball
i don't think so i i have watched some
sports recently
um and they've been piping in the the
fan
noise which has been throwing me off um
i would like to watch something like a
rugby match from new zealand
just because they have all the full
stadium and that would be cool to see
and i'm so excited
for all of them um but no probably not
yeah well the last positive thing i'll
say about the nba is that most players
have been using all their media time
uh to talk about social justice issues
and things they care about so there has
been a very positive message coming out
of the league as well
um so they're they're trying to make the
most of it and the food has gotten
better
because we talked about this last time
the players are complaining about the
food
supposedly it's gotten a lot better um
and then the yeah the players complained
as well because it was like one food
conglomerate that owned a bunch of
restaurant groups
and they uh asked nate demanded to have
some black owned restaurants that were
offered and the league quickly
changed course and now they're they're
offering a lot of
uh food from a bunch of black owned
restaurants so that's really cool as
well
but we'll see how it turns out um that's
all i got
you are a professional sports player
please write it and let us know your
thoughts
even anonymously we know that a lot of
professional athletes
listen to this podcast dennis rodman
please email us i know
we got dr bev alec only knows the 90s
bulls and i love it so yeah
players in nba jam the greatest video
game that's ever existed
that game was so good boom shakalaka um
well great well before we move on then
we do want to give a shout out to
noah dee who's one of our patrons he was
in the hangout the other day he's on the
stream right now
you could be as cool as him if you also
become a patron
the most exclusive club on the internet
the dennis rodman scottie pippen
charles barkley they're all patrons none
of that's true but maybe
um so next yeah i'm very excited to hear
about this topic i'm sure everyone else
is
i've seen this meme all over the
internet and i i don't know what it
means so i'm excited to learn about it
serbia why why do we gotta free britney
oh gosh i have like
pages and pages of notes um i went deep
so first of all i love brittany my very
first concert was a brightening concert
so i totally just aged myself there um
i will always root for britney she's
she's the best so
hashtag freebritney you may have seen
this
you may not know what it is so tess
sparker and barbara gray
are the originators of the hashtag free
britney movement
they have a podcast called britney's
gram
and they did an episode last year called
free brittany
and the reason why they did it is that
britney suddenly disappeared
like she wasn't being photographed she
wasn't on social media she cancelled her
uh las vegas um concert residency
and it was really weird so they started
talking about it
and that's what sparked it so for those
of you who don't know brittany
uh was super popular in the early 2000s
oh they
know there's no one that doesn't know
who britney spears is i don't know what
if there is like
we might have like super young people
who are hearing here's what i know about
if you're
nine go do go back to your parents room
you shouldn't be here
i feel like we should level set for
everyone she was super popular in the
early 2000s she dated chess and
timberlake
okay and then she shaved her head that's
what i understand
britney spears pop star shaves her head
start from there that's why i
started buzzing my head i saw britney's
haircut and i was just like that's for
me
i could have long full hair if i wanted
to but i want that look
so between 2007 and 2008 she had a long
drawn out mental breakdown
she shaved her head she was film-shaving
her head she was attacking paparazzi
with an umbrella
she was taken away a couple of times
strapped to a gurney
for an involuntary psychiatric and
in 2008 she uh
the court created a conservatorship over
her estate assets and personal
well-being
so 12 years later it's still in effect
and understood
it's like a legal guardianship so she
has somebody who has to make all of her
decisions for her so she can't
say like i'm gonna enter into this
contract with
coca-cola she has somebody else who's
like
yes you will enter this contract with
coca-cola or no you will not
um so it's not the same for like even
like marriage and things like that she
would have to get
approval so she's like functionally and
i don't mean this glibly like a child at
the legal level
right so she
under the terms of her conservatorship
she can't make
any key decisions personal or financial
like you two said
without the approval of her conservators
so at the time it was her dad
jamie spears and a lawyer andrew wallet
so every every decision from the
smallest things like buying a drink at
starbucks
or buying a song on itunes to having
like a sponsorship
everything had to be approved and
documented
and the conservators were paid very well
her dad earned 128 000 for being her
conservator
the attorney asked for a raise received
it
and at the end made 426 000
for being her conservator like a year
over like 10 years
a year every year so for the past 12
years
so here's where things get even weirder
so there is speculation that she uses
instagram
as a way to plea for help because her
appearances are tightly controlled so
you don't see britney in interviews you
don't see her
doing too much um so over the past 12
years she's been
like more and more closed off and
there's less and less access to her
so in one post someone commented saying
if you need help wear a yellow shirt and
in the next post
britney posed in a yellow shirt and like
wrote a comment saying here i
am and my favorite yellow shirt and
something about like a florist
and there's also speculation that some
of the photos and videos aren't actually
britney
so we have a photo here if joy can put
up
and this photo is supposedly of britney
spears
and her boyfriend and if you zoom in
super close
on the woman it does not look like
britney spears
and like the mouth the eyes like nothing
looks like britney
and the comments on this photo are all
saying that's not her like who is this
woman
um and in a lot of her other photos on
instagram she somebody
somebody liking these photographs to
like a hostage
like a hostage photo like where she's
just like staring
into the camera like straight faced um
she just looks very very sad so last
year following a physical altercation
with one of brittany's sons
her dad uh temporarily stepped down as
her conservator
and before that the attorney stepped
down as well
so right now britney's case manager
stepped in
and there's a hearing in august to
determine the future of the
conservatorship
britney's mom has filed uh
paperwork to become more involved in her
daughter's financial
decisions and this is why the free
britney movement has been surging
again in the news and it appears that
britney hates the conservatorship
she said that what separates the a
conservatorship
from a jail sentence is that her
conservatorship is never ending
and there's a ton of other like super
weird stuff that has gone on
um but i'll keep it concise for this
so i'm deeply saddened and disturbed
what do you two think
i
some of it sounds a little like
far-fetched i'll say
except i do think with conservatorships
i think they're really tricky and this
kind of gets to the britney spears
problem
because in one sense they're often for
let's say your elderly
parent has dementia and they cannot be
you know signing checks or making legal
decisions or revising their will because
they are not mentally competent to do so
like that makes a lot of sense and so
that's like kind of the need for them
or uh you know there's lots of other
cases in like with
mental illness and uh so on but
at the same time i think and
this is not a conspiracy like people
take advantage of them often
you know i i'm sure there's plenty of
anecdotal examples of
you know mom is rich and the kids are
really greedy and shitty so they have
her
you know sent to a nursing home and gets
some shitty lawyer to say that they're
not mentally competent and then like
rewrite the will to their liking
and so on and so forth and so i think
especially when there's a lot of money
involved i think we should be
i guess super super vigilant about it
um at the same time like britney spears
is a
celebrity like none of us know her and
so i'm also wary to
say like oh i know that she's actually
like
super with it and doesn't need this or
you know like a similar example with
kanye
um you know not that a similar thing's
happening but
we're not the psychiatrist you know
diagnosing him or talking to him
we're not mental health experts um
you know and so when it comes to oh [ __ ]
like does kanye need to be like
sent somewhere or need this kind of
treatment like i'm just not super
comfortable saying that and
uh the other side of it that you
mentioned that i think is also
interesting is that
she's a young person and this is like
forever and
i think you know again i don't know what
her situation is but a lot of
situations that might sort of need that
might not be permanent you know if
someone
has a downward spiral with drugs and
alcohol like i think she did that
doesn't mean that they're not
mentally competent for the rest of their
life a lot of people sort of come back
from that so
i don't know yeah
all that and uh i mean even if
she has needed this at one point it's
just hard to imagine how you get out of
it
because the skills you would need to
manage yourself are skills you're not
able to develop when someone's doing all
these things for you
it's like if i had a baby and rather
than letting it walk i just carried it
everywhere it's not going to learn how
to walk and its legs won't work right
because i'm carrying it but it's not
going to learn how to walk until i put
it down
i don't have a kid so please no one
called child services it was just a bad
analogy
but it just seems like where is she
going to get the space to develop these
skills
and it almost sounds like if you're in
and i know nothing about this legally
but why not have like a sort of easing
off process
where she proves herself able to make
these financial decisions so they ease
off of that
then she's able to prove herself a fit
parent in these ways so they ease off of
that
rather than this weird all or nothing
like it sounds
it just sounds really horrible but that
said i don't know if i all
if i uh believe all of the
conspiratorial stuff because we just
love conspiracy theories so much we want
them to be true
but so i know my question about like the
yellow shirt for instance are fans
basically
ordering like a thousand different
things that are like wear green shirt
wear yellow shirt and then she just so
happened to like
wear a color you know or
yeah so now they're starting to do that
i don't know if they were doing that
back then
yeah um and the other part of it is like
you know one case she is fully mentally
competent
and is truly doing this on the other
hand you know
uh again i don't know what her diagnosis
is but let's just say
she was you know paranoid maybe like
some bipolar thing somewhere to kanye
where she thinks everyone's out to get
her
like there's a world where she is
like oh my father's out to get me and my
conservators are out to get me
and yeah like i'm gonna wear this yellow
dress because like i'm a prisoner
and in that case is her audience kind of
if that is the case or is the audience
feeding into that delusion you know
but but again like it's i i'm not there
i don't know like and i'm not like an
expert on the britney and her father
relationship
yeah serbia is it also the case then
that when
she was or is doing the vegas residency
that all the money she's making which i
imagine
is a lot of money that she does not have
direct access to is she so she's
essentially
making money that maybe just like is
going to her family and other people
while she is the sort of like
show pony that gets put on stage to make
money for others
so i do think that her finances are
tightly controlled by the court as well
you have to document everything so i
don't think it's
i mean it's possible but i don't think
that it's super easy for
the dad to like take that money and put
it in like an offshore account for
himself
so i mean maybe he's getting paid under
the table or something but i do think
that you have to provide records of like
all financial transactions um to ensure
that there's no mismanagement on the
part of the conservators
so i want to add two things so
one i do agree with um michael your
your idea that there should be like an
easing off period because her brother
made a comment that said something like
she's had a she's been a like a
celebrity since she was 15.
and she's never had to learn how to do
anything so it would be really hard for
her to learn how to do it now
um and i also think that if the
conservators are in charge
of every aspect of her life then is it
possible that because they're being paid
so much money
they're not impartial it's in their
financial best interest to keep her in a
conservatorship
so could they like withhold her
medication at times so that she has a
mental relapse which then reinforces the
need for conservatorship
i think that there should be like an
impartial third party like there is
right now with the case manager
and if there is to be some sort of
um like if the if the person has to be
paid for their time
then there should be some sort of cap so
that it's not like
she's doling out 428 000
to somebody it should be something
that's more reasonable that you're not
going to get rich off of
yeah because right now it's like it's
her dad and it's like well that's not
impartial and
it's an attorney who's making 428
thousand dollars a year like
we don't know if he has her best
interest at heart and were her
was her dad one of those uh helicopter
parents the wrong word
but like oh i want to make my kid famous
and that's why because she was a disney
kid right she was
so kids so i don't trust him already
yeah
i don't know that he was that i mean i
do think that he did
when she was a little bit older like in
her 20s i do think
he was more involved but i think i read
an article at one point that said that
he was
like a kind of abusive and an alcoholic
growing up
so i don't know that he's been the most
solid
parent gotcha well i was gonna say a lot
of times
the sort of uh toddlers in tear
the crowd those parents are just like
exploiting their kid for their own
weird fantasies about being famous or
rich or whatever
so she did that as well she was like in
pageants and all of that
so i think the family is a little bit
into
into that i mean i don't know the spears
clan but
i've been converted to the hashtag free
britney camp
by the end of this conversation so if
that was your goal serbia you have
succeeded
uh overwhelmingly so i'm i'm i'm
i'm leaning more towards it i'm still a
little uncomfortable but like
maybe like a tentative maybe free
britney
i think that's still a good good
performance progress
before we move on uh any any action in
the chat that we needed to
to respond to any anything going on in
there oh
uh my my non-traditional i've just been
talking uh kind of about
some of the scare aspects of our mental
health care system people
being uh involuntarily confined in
places and
again it's the same thing of you know
sometimes you have to protect people for
their safety but also
our psychiatric institutions have an
awful awful track record of being
really bad uh watch one flew over the
cuckoo's nest it's based in reality
uh yeah makes me think of that
soderbergh film
insane from a couple years ago that he
shot on an iphone that was
very disturbing that's all check it out
it's a good movie though
um well so speaking of of disturbing
things
alec what's going on with the new
pandemic action and conspiratorial
aspects of the
current public health crisis oh yeah so
uh pandemic is old news at this point
but i have some
new news about it and for anyone who's
not on board it was uh
a quote unquote documentary film even
though it was like 30 minutes i watched
the whole thing
uh it's this woman uh i think it's judy
mykovitz
yeah judy micawitz uh who
has lots of claims about lots of things
in this about how she was arrested for
no reason which is not true she stole
materials from her employer uh and then
you know
the law came after her uh she claims
that like fauci was manufacturing the
coronavirus
uh she claims lots of things oh that
also make us
more sick because it it's just stupid
i'm not gonna even
repeat it um but uh you know there's a
lot of coverage about
why all these claims are bad if you're
interested
go on you know snopes or just google
there's a lot of great news articles
about all the the misrepresentations in
this movie
what is interesting is that sinclair
media which is a
their company that owns a lot of local
news stations in the united states over
193 across the country
um they aired a segment on their
show america this week with uh eric
bowling who used to host a
uh fox news show
this is from a guardian article on it
fyi if anyone's interested
um and so they were going to air this
segment with an interview of her and her
lawyer
some claims in there happen uh some of
the claims in there
uh for instance are that we gave the the
u.s gave 3.7 million to wuhan labs for
this coronavirus uh the fact is that the
wuhan
uh sorry we gave money for the study uh
to eco health alliances who are studying
coronaviruses and other things in bats
there's lots of coronaviruses including
ones that kill cats
uh that have been doing so for years and
years and years uh sars etc etc
anyway uh they make a claim like this
he's the the lawyer is trying to sue
uh dr fauci for manufacturing and
sending this virus to wuhan
um it then cuts to a doctor from uh the
sloan-kettering uh
cancer center which is a very
prestigious cancer thing this person is
a radiologist
uh uh with not a virologist or any of
the experts there
um who who says like hey i don't really
believe that you know this is a man-made
virus like micaovitz but uh we should
maybe look into the evidence i think
the evidence is pointing to the fact
that it was you know a natural occurring
thing but but let's check it out
um and just i i did look into this
specific claim
uh that's also not true people have done
gene sequencing of
sars cov2 and found that there is no
evidence of
gene altering you would find sort of
trademarks of non-randomness that you
wouldn't find in nature it's been
peer-reviewed and published
but what i find really interesting about
this and
uh you know sinclair planning to air it
they eventually
after backlash decide not to air it but
it's online if people want to watch the
the interview
um it's just the way that people will
air certain pseudo-scientific things for
the sake of like
showing both sides or airing the debate
it's the thing the media often does and
i think it's
a lot of the research i've come across
is that a lot of the worst
pseudoscience gets perpetrated this way
and i think there's like this great
moment
where uh bowling the host
said uh about one of mykovitz's claim oh
that's a hefty claim
not like hey let's dive into the proof
that you're saying fauci manufacturing
sense it's just like
that seems kind of like intense like oh
i wonder if that's rooted in things and
then you know they cut
to this uh person sloan kettering who's
an actual doctor but not a virologist or
any related field
to discount but not really discount it
um
similar things have happened uh there's
been like anti-vax documentaries about
like dbt
which is uh for diphtheria pertussis and
tetanus
uh a lot of bunk claims in a documentary
that was i think in the 80s or 90s and
all the news stations aired it and had
interviews with the people who made it
saying like we just want to hear the
side and we're here
you know like let's let's air out the
truth so that we can sort of
figure out what it is you know
marketplace of all ideas and it doesn't
really work unless you're a very good
journalist like if boeing wanted to have
this lady on and be
fully armed with all the facts and sort
of destroy her with facts and logic as
they say like
that's often what good journalists do
but all he could really muster was
that's a hefty claim and also said he
was not even he hadn't even seen her
videos before having her on the show so
sorry i could ramble on and on but i
guess the real question here
is how do you feel about like obviously
news uh documenting sort of
disagreements over political issues or
even scientific issues is important part
of the democratic process
but at what point do we have to say like
oh no we're not going to
uh put on this insane conspiracy theory
uh or this doctor who thinks that like
demon genes are
infecting us well like it'd be one thing
right if one local news station had the
demon gene doctor on
the horrifying thing is that a media
corporation with a very specific
ideological bent owned by a small group
of rich people is able to produce
segments and send them out across the
nation
to to perpetuate the stuff which is very
scary
um so that sucks and i don't think is
democratic in any good way or real way
but it's weird like when i first hear
stuff like this it's kind of funny in a
sick way
but then my brain goes towards a lot of
people are going to see stuff like this
and as we approach an era where knock on
wood hopefully we have a vaccine
people will not take it because of stuff
like this which will have
you know ripple effects in terms of
public health and that's that's really
scary
and and i think when like when
disinformation
and conspiratorial um
things like this can lead to you know
real people getting sick
it's it's kind of scary not to be too
too grim or serious about it
yeah serving i
i i agree with both of you i
i mean i wish there could be some sort
of disclaimer that would say like
this is like fiction and this goes
against
science and peer-reviewed studies and
things but
the people who put that on would never
include a disclaimer like that
um i don't know what the answer is i
mean you don't
want to censor things too much because
how where do you draw the line and i
think it's a slippery slope
um but at the same time i think
something like this can cause more harm
because
it's like michael said with the vaccines
people won't take it and also
it
we risk exposing this to people who may
not know
where the information is coming from if
they don't take
a second to do like research
on where they gathered those those
statements from
so they might just hear this and think
oh is this what's happening is this
what's going on and then run with it
and that's dangerous too because then
they start doing it and then we get like
the facebook
like chains and all this like everybody
be careful if you open this message
like bill gates will not send you a
million dollars or whatever that kind of
stuff
um i don't know what the answer is i
mean i i wish we could just ban it but
then
yeah i i think uh uh you know the sort
of like we have to hear both sides of
the debate news is eager to exploit it
because it's sensational whether
it's about like autism or vaccines or
even like climate change
one i forget what book it is but had the
distinction between a political versus
scientific controversy
you know uh masks are not a scientific
controversy they're a political
controversy which is to say that like
there's not meaningful disagreement
among scientists um
and i think
there i think like as a counter example
of like it's not that we should just
like accept whatever the scientific
community puts out or something
uh and like if there's a minority of
scientists saying something we shouldn't
listen to them
but like a good example of this is the
who
says that you know covet is not airborne
it's droplet-based but like
over 200 scientists signed a letter
saying like hey actually we think
there's evidence that
it's airborne and i haven't gone to
science i don't know what it is but
it seems like it was grounded in reality
enough for the who to say like oh
actually we hear your concerns we're
going to look at it
and like that's the way for it to work
not like oh there's literally like five
scientists we found who are idiots
uh who agree with us and uh one
real sort of very tangential thing but
just about how like media
can catapult in very dangerous ways
pseudoscience is i always
had the notion that lobotomy speaking of
mental health crises
uh lobotomies were just like the science
of the time and they got it wrong
but i was reading this paul offit book
uh and the way he describes it is that
really there was like
one or two or a handful of people at
least in america pushing these things
and most of the psychiatric community
was like this is an awful idea do not
drill parts of people's brains out
uh the guy who was really famous for
doing america started just doing it with
an ice pick
and he was a neurologist he wasn't a
surgeon at first he started with the
surgeon
drilling into people's brains and was
like [ __ ] it i can do it with my office
and ice pick
so it was never real science but at the
same time the new york times was saying
like
this new miracle cure and like the
kennedys famously lobotomized their
daughter who had developmental issues um
and like that's the danger of like
turning your child into a zombie because
like the new york times or cnn or fox
news published a story about like
some dumb fad uh that the media made it
seem
like there was more scientific merit
than the scientific community ever
believed in
yeah i mean it seems this just taps into
a very scary large-scale crisis
of authority uh and something i think
it's currently really bad right now in
terms of like science and public health
the it just seems like there's not like
any fixed
epistemological ground upon which we can
say this
is like true and there's some like space
of truth and consensus and over here
is falsehood misinformation things
really feel like a free-for-all right
now and i think especially
there's i think a lot of older folks um
came came of age in an era where the
media was associated with some sort of
truth consensus
stability or whatever like the walter
cronkite era or whatever it might have
been
and i feel like that has taken over
where now
if in your brain from a young age like
oh the media can only say stuff if it's
true the media says things that are fact
checked
well then like online spaces become the
media
and you kind of take on that same set of
assumptions like i think i've seen this
with
she doesn't watch her listen to this who
cares like my mother who's old
um you know see stuff on facebook or
something like that
and takes it as seriously as she would
a news report by a dan rather or
something like that
uh and i think i don't know for
me at least that's one of the things i
see happening and and something that i
find so scary about all of this
well yeah and also back in the day when
we would just trust the media
uh that also is with its fault like the
new york times was talking about
lobotomies i think in the age of like
we trust the media mm-hmm and it was a
health journalist doing a very bad job
of reporting the facts so
uh god what's his name the
the science guy uh the philosopher bill
nye
no no no the philosopher who people
accuse of being like anti-science
um he recently said something like i was
warning people like that the facts like
like resorting to the facts alone will
not save us like there there needs to be
some better framework and you guys just
all assumed that i thought that there
was no objective truth and i
i think about that a lot yeah and it's
just too like that not to be too nerdy
about it but
it's just like that lack of a of a sense
of like
critical thinking skills and i'm not
trying to call people stupid but i think
it's a practice
that we don't have as much as a culture
anymore
of like critically engaging with sources
and having like confidence in our own
intellectual abilities
to navigate and sort through these
things and i think that's a
a scary place to be in yeah
um i just want to thank chris tomski
who uh not only donated but said
the media did the same thing with tide
pods i think it's a little different but
i think it's related uh covering the
news
made the situation worse they have no
responsibility right now just their
bottom line
yeah yeah okay but yeah if media sources
didn't cover
a lot of like these batshit you know
doctors
or documentaries they wouldn't get as
much hype and many of us end up watching
this stuff because of that so
yeah pods indeed um any other thoughts
on
on this one as we're all feeling good
not for me
getting to the voicemails yeah let's do
that but before we do
um you all know this uh we love hearing
from you so much we love reading your
words so much so
please email us at culturebinge
at wisecrack.conom justacnno
or call us because hearing your voice is
great two one three five three four
eight eight oh seven once again that's
two on three five three four eight eight
oh seven
truly it's one of the joys of this
podcast is seeing what you all care
about how you respond what we're talking
about
and to see things you might want to hear
us talk about in the future so please
get in touch with us we love it
without further ado alec who do we get
to hear from this year
i think we have a voicemail joy can you
play the one from yeah i think they're
anonymous
they aren't oh the the hacker group hi
everyone this is for culture ginge
i just want to talk a little bit about
tiktok as someone who does use that
i'm very cynical about the data
collection thing only because like you
all pointed out
full apps collect data varying degrees
and sadly i think the only
way for people to truly have privacy in
this day and age is to get rid of their
smartphones and use a library computer
all that being said i wanted to
highlight a part of tick tock that i
don't really see people talk about
um the app actually has been a very good
place for people to keep
informed about political issues and
particularly during
the blm protests um during its peak my
page was flooded with videos of people
at protests
documenting incidents of police
brutality and also
giving tips on how to safely attend
protests by
keeping your identity sealed
and stuff like that um i just want to
bring this up because i feel like
especially on sites like reddit the app
is pretty much dismissed as
being something that's like dumb kids
use when in actuality it does have a
very
strong and active political community
um yes that's pretty much it thank you
guys for a wonderful
podcast thank you
yeah and just in case anyone listening
live couldn't hear that
um uh the the anonymous caller
uh we're just talking about what we
mentioned with tick tock and anonymity
and data and how even though it gets a
bad rap all our apps collect data in
certain ways and the tick tock
um for this caller was really useful in
recent protests and finding out about
where things were how to act getting
good information
and they were saying they think that
tick tock can get a bad rap on other
sites uh particularly like reddit where
it's a
you know quote-unquote dumb kid thing so
thank you so much for that
what do you all think
i uh i i like this call and they
actually remind me there's um
i think there's a there's a tendency
uh at least in philosophy sorry i'm
gonna go on a jock grants here
quick quick little tangent but do it um
i i think a lot about there's this one
specific uh
moment where he talks about there's this
kind of tradition in uh
at least a certain kind of philosophy
that's kind of like people are dumb and
inundated by like ideology that
brainwashes them and i think
you could sort of pull things about how
like tick tock distracts us and mtv
makes us stupid and
all these things and i think whether or
not you're one of these philosophers
it's
the the logical a lot of people operate
in but his sort of
retort to that is you know you could
consider people
brainwashed under ideology that they're
too mired in it to see the truth but in
fact it's the only ground that they have
to stand on
and i think this tick tock example is
good is that like tick-tock is like a
dumb app doing dumb things that's
probably spying on you in ways and
selling your data
but at the same time it's really the
only thing that people have to work with
so that
you know uh whether you're
you know protesting something or trying
to spread a specific kind of message
like
that's what you have to work with and i
i think uh
yeah i feel i mean the company aside
tiktok as a medium i feel fine about
like yeah yeah i really felt that
voicemail
yeah i mean i don't know every time i
see stuff from tick tock i'm so
impressed by
two things one how funny a lot of young
people are and how they use tik tok
um yeah like the the the some of the
best comedy is being produced by people
on tik-tok and that's awesome
and then the flip side is i'm so
impressed by how socially conscious
politically active and intellectually
curious so many young people and gen z
people are
on there where they have like tick tock
videos that mix contemporary underground
rap music with
uh you know manifestos about
anti-colonization and stuff it's wild
and it's so cool
and i think like the the this caller
points out something important if we're
going to do this thing where
all of a sudden tick-tock is the bad one
we can't use like
just you know throw away your tv and
computer
move to the country like john prine told
you to and
read books and learn how to farm because
there's there's no like
uh ethical way to participate in digital
media spaces and on these apps anyway so
oh no i felt that call thank you for
calling anonymous and
anonymous if you're out there please use
your hacking skills to erase all student
loan debt
um service i wonder if it's because
china it's a
company that originated in china so we
are uncomfortable with
a chinese company having our data if it
was someone like
if it was like based in the uk and like
the british government was taking our
data would people mind as much
yeah yeah i think it's really it's uh
people want to simplify it a lot to say
like china evil america good
uh when it's like a lot of what about us
and like you don't want to say oh
don't worry about like the possibility
that the chinese government would be
collecting your data because google is
therefore like don't pay attention that
i think the better
answer is to say uh oh yeah this is bad
lots of other things are bad let's try
to like look at this overall
because um and you could legitimately
say you know
uh i think the uk government is not the
chinese the chinese government you know
um and so i think separating it from
like a certain kind of like
scaremongering that wants to like beat
the war drum against china or something
like that while realizing that the
chinese government is
is pretty awful um not that you know
other governments aren't pretty awful
but again it's not a what about ism it's
like let's
let's take a holistic picture about all
the ways that all the governments are
awful in their own unique ways
yeah i only want sociopathic harvard
dropouts to have my data
he can have all that he wants at any
time zuckerberg i'll die for you
um we're do we have any emails this year
yeah we gotta we got a few awesome
um if you want to email us again
culturebinge wisecrack.co
here's one from rachel uh since we hear
a lot about michael's current obsession
with love reality tv especially on
netflix i was curious if you have seen
love on the spectrum
if you haven't you need to curious what
you think extending from your previous
thoughts on love especially when it
concerns minority population of people
with disabilities
how can we make life more accessible and
after the viewing the show
what love on the spectrum has taught you
about the concepts of dating romance and
relationships have you seen it michael
i haven't i will be watching it very
shortly i watched the first episode last
night
it was wonderful what what service is
this on
or platform oh my god great um well
thank you so much
for for recommending that i need more of
this in my life
um so i'm gonna watch it soon yeah
that sounds awesome i really like that
there's a show about it because i think
there are quite a few misconceptions
about
autism and people on the spectrum and
things like people
think that maybe they're not
i mean i'm just hypothesizing but maybe
they're not capable of like
deep romantic relationships so it's nice
that there's a show to
demonstrate that no like everybody is
worthy and accessible to love yeah and i
also think it's like
very relatable in a way in that like
like there's one guy
who i has like i know it's not a
normal distinction anymore but he's the
term that he has asperger's except he
has an australian accent so he says in
some crazy way
um but uh he just has like a lot of
notions about love that i think are like
very
rigid and kind of wrong but i identify
with it because it's like oh that's kind
of what i thought love was like when i
was a teenager and then like i had to
like go through this process and like i
hope
he also kind of grows in that way too
again i'm only on the first episode so
we'll see
awesome can't wait to check that out
yeah uh what's next
so this one is from also uh
an uh anonymous evil hacker um hey
culture binge crew this is redacted from
new england been listening since episode
one
just started your episode on sports in a
covid world that was last episode and
i'm also an emt that transports critical
care patients including kovid
and i have to call out dr burns for his
respect towards the basketball player
who broke quarantine just to get food
from postmates
couple of reasons postmates is terrible
they steal hundreds of dollars from
restaurants that they're trying to
survive during covid
okay fair enough reason two the delivery
driver will most
definitely be coming contact dozens of
people in the near future
sorry he didn't really around i'm
cutting it short but sorry if the rant
seems angry not mad at you just matt the
player who did that love the show
can't wait to listen the rest of the
episode he's completely right
i'm completely wrong i can admit it i
was being glib
you're right and i think we've talked
about it on the show i will say this if
you listen to every episode there is
evidence on the show of me talking about
food delivery services being bad and
exploitative
i guarantee it because i said it was bad
and then serbia said they're the best
never tip
um kidding uh but no that that's
completely right and i think that like
once again i think like i said earlier
in this episode the the key to the nba
thing working is people actually
following those rules
and not doing that stuff so 100
that's all i i'm sorry i hang my head in
shame
and thank you for listening to this
podcast well here's mike i guess what i
was imagining is like he went past the
quarantine zone
and like met him in a parking lot and he
like put it down and walked away but
maybe that's not what happened maybe
they should
i think that's what faces no i think
what happened was there's like literally
a line the driver went up to like
where he was legally allowed to go put
the food down
backed away and then the the
professional athlete went and got it
still not good but it's not you know
he's not
you know breathing in his face yeah and
i think what we
you know take away from all this is some
of these professional athletes god bless
them
um a little spoiled they make a lot of
money they get to eat awesome food all
the time and
play games on really nice tvs and and
things in their life are pretty dope so
at first they were like
i'm locked into a hotel for middle class
families on vacation
eating hotel food please get me out of
here so
that's a good email and you're right uh
we got any more for this this week yeah
uh last one
is wow everyone's anonymous and doesn't
want their name being said but
wow i wouldn't find you this
is a person from new zealand who says
just wanted to say
to michael if he misses sports there's
still plenty of sports being played
around the world
i'm pretty sure you can find some high
level basketball being played uh
somewhere not just at the same hype
level as the nba
i know here in new zealand rugby is back
on it's a huge part of our culture the
point where it's actually part
actually part of people's identities
here so maybe take some time
out and experience some other sports
from other countries
that's awesome i i briefly when i lived
in england i got really into rugby for a
while because i wanted to be into a live
sport
um so that's awesome advice and i've
watched a little bit of basketball in
germany and spain
um which is great but yeah new zealand's
just the best
what what what is what is there to say
about new zealand right now that isn't
just like
bravo well done some i really like their
prime minister
jacinda she's so good uh there was some
[ __ ] chitlord on reddit who was like
here's a pic of me at the rugby game in
new zealand we get to be outside and
have fun because we have zero cases [ __ ]
you
they didn't say [ __ ] you america that
was how i was reading in my head that's
fair no no it's fair i was again not a
sports fan but i was like i would even
go to sports stadium to drink a beer
outside if it was safe to do so
but alas we don't live in new zealand
that's awesome so thank you for writing
thank you for taunting us with the fact
that your
country has confident leadership and a
populist that seemed like
down to uh take care of things you get
back to what matters
i still think if we just would have had
a mar we need a marketing campaign
in this country that that everything is
framed around an event
like if you want to go to concerts again
or sports again sacrifice now party
later
if anyone from the government of any
country wants to hire me to come up with
this marketing campaign
i'm ready to go i got ideas for days i
think we should just make jacinda
the ruler of the world yeah let's have
an overlord
a one world ruler she'll get us under
control it'll be so good yes
bend the knee that's great an
authoritarian who doesn't
know okay well uh
once again i would tip new zealanders so
write in tell survey why she's a tip and
while
one world authoritarian governments
could be problematic and you can write
in to let us know about that at
culturebinge
wisecrack.com once again 213-534-8807
and of course we mentioned it at the top
if you want another way to get in touch
with us be involved
get deeper into the wisecrack community
um patreon.com
wisecrack hit us up there check it out i
think it's worth a go
you can always cancel it if it doesn't
work out for you but it will work out
for you
um so before we go um where can
folks find you all if they need more of
you in their lives
serbia siripatel22 on twitter
also i do tip in case you're just tuning
in we're just this is just a
long-standing joke
write me on the low it'll be anonymous i
want to know the real
story no i don't like it when you go to
the restaurant and they're like oh we
you have to tip like twenty percent so
what i don't want to get into it again
we will say this uh
michael doesn't wipe or sorry no michael
doesn't wash his hands after he wipes
yeah uh i'm perfect i'm just kidding uh
i'm on twitter at wisecrack alec it's
it's right
how do i where's where's the camera uh
it's right there
but before you do that become a patron
it's cool it's cool yeah become a patron
um yeah and i'm at
michael o'burns on twitter follow me
there and if you ever are really bored
i'm starting to do some weekly
philosophy streams where i rant about
philosophy stuff and get real nerdy
uh we did one before it's fun a few
philosophy professor friends dropped in
oh you check it out but be a patron
be a patron this is the best thing you
do so for
for alec and serbi i'm michael this has
been culture binge become a patron and
we'll see you in a couple weeks
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you